next caller at six one seven eight three
zero forty seven fifty is from the seven
eight zero area code caller what's your
name and where you're calling from hi
there my name is Erin and I'm calling
from Edmonton Canada great what's on
your mind I am NOT currently watching
your show
David because I don't think that I can
be watching while I'm calling in so I
apologize if this question has been
asked but do you think that did ask some
irrational and impulsive reaction fault
failed to be mitigated in any way by any
level-headed person in the Trump
administration may lead to his undoing
being the handling of the call me
situation and whatever cover up whether
it's bigger than the actual crime or the
crying that they're covering up right um
do you think to see at most you know
I've been thinking about this a lot over
the last couple of days what would the
firing of James Comey and you know the
reaction from many Republicans has been
disbelief and certainly they're not
pleased with the decision that Donald
Trump made and so I started wondering
was there an assumption from the Trump
administration that Republicans would
get behind the firing of James Comey and
they just misread it or did they make
the decision with absolutely no regard
for how Republicans were going to react
but yeah it I've been thinking a lot Pat
about this idea that these haphazard
decisions equivalent to sending out an
ill-advised erratic tweet that they
could have repercussions and would the
Comey firing I mean many Republicans
were saying this makes no sense to us
what is he doing I really don't think
that the Trump administration expected
there to be much blowback because they
probably thought Republicans don't like
Comey Democrats don't like komen isn't
going to be major news and it rocked the
whole world maybe so maybe so yeah and I
think there's still we still need more
time to figure out the full fallout from
the firing of James Comey but I think
there's a lot to what you're saying I
think that that's it's a it's the right
question to be asking that's for sure
okay well you know I guess we'll see
that's the nature of it is general if
I'm allowed to make a comment I see this
as sort of Donald Trump's own
sociopathic tendencies finally coming to
roost to the point where he isn't going
perhaps isn't going to be able to find
some ridiculous way to get himself out
of this like I said whether the crime is
that significant or the steps he takes
to cover it up undo him but I mean I was
curious to your opinion because yeah he
never seems too surprised in terms of
what could come next to how people start
asking the wrong questions I think it's
more narcissism and delusions of
grandeur than sociopathy when I see this
type of thing what do you think that
well it probably didn't help that his
first couple days as president were met
by him disparaging the intelligence
community right not a very good idea
because those people could have dirt on
you yeah not a good way to start Aaron
thank you so much for the call always
great to hear from our viewers in Canada
very very much appreciated